oh man this this galaxy that we just
found with jwst is 13 billion light
years away it no it isn't or is it maybe
at some point but not when that light
left and not when it has arrived
uhhuh hey crazies welcome to another
installment of wife reacts this is my
wife awkward M hello okay so how
familiar are you with how we measure
distances in space Oh I'm not at all
familiar at all okay if you wanted to
measure the length of something what
would you do I would grab some kind of
measuring tool so like a tape measure or
a ruler or something yes what about if
the distance was just a little bit
longer like maybe Detroit to Chicago I
would use Google Maps for sure okay what
if the distance is so far away that we
don't have access to the other end of
the trip do you mean we don't have
access like it's in the middle of the
ocean and you can't drive that far or
like no because then you could still use
a boat and get there okay right I'm
talking like Mars what do you do what do
you do if you want to figure out what
the distance to Mars is and you can't go
there mhm thankfully in the last you
know little bit we have gone there a
couple times at least uh with probes and
stuff so right do probes have
odometers say it's 1920 mhm and we don't
have any space program yet there's no
there's no such thing as a space probe
haven't even been to the Moon right how
do you figure out the distance to the
moon or to Mars or to Saturn or to other
stars in the in the universe you don't
I'm just kidding I have no idea well
this is a problem that scientists
astronomers were facing that we've been
facing for a long time sure we're going
to do this in stages each of these
techniques represents a rung and
something we call the distance ladder so
the techniques kind of stack on top of
each other right we use one technique to
calibrate the next and then use it to
stretch across the next Gap okay and so
as we move forward we're going to get
into larger and larger distances from
Earth
sure first off we have something we call
radar ranging radar itself the word
radar is actually an acronym it stands
for radio detection and ranging okay and
so if you say radar ranging you're
basically saying radio detection and
ranging ranging well this is what we do
in our language though so here we are
right but basically the idea is that we
can send some kind of radio signal out
it'll reflect off of something and come
back in that case you might be thinking
like we're sending it out to some space
probe we sent out and we're bouncing it
back which does happen but we were able
to do this before that which means
you're actually bouncing it off of an
object right so radar was invented in
the like early to mid-30s by a handful
of countries almost like simultaneously
it was one of those things that like it
was time historically speaking we were
ready for it and everyone just kind kind
of happened to happened on it all at
once sure I'm comfortable with that
right now we didn't actually use it for
astronomy until the 40s like the mid to
late 40s when someone thought you know
what what if I try to reflect a radio
signal off the moon and so they sent a
signal straight to the moon and it
bounced off and came back and they
picked up the signal wow that must
exciting it's a big deal yeah but even
even that reflecting the signal off the
Moon is kind of a a pain when you're
just reflecting it off of moon rock sure
so in the 60s late 60s when we finally
landed on the moon we were able to put a
reflector down sure I imagine it would
have to be pretty big or else your
instruments would have to be very
specific I'm I'm guessing maybe
something like this it's a pretty
precise instrument that's going to be
able to hit that right but it gives us a
much more accurate measurement of the
distance to the Moon and that's how we
know that it's you know exactly so many
miles or kilometers up there sure the
furthest we've ever been able to measure
with this method is Saturn mhm which is
pretty far it is it is pretty far it has
to go all the way to Saturn and then
come all the way back before we actually
receive it which makes it remarkable
that we even made it to Saturn to begin
with right we have this thing called the
inverse Square law have you ever heard
of the inverse Square law yeah have I I
have heard of it for sure do I remember
what it is it's like as it goes as light
goes out it becomes dimmer right is the
gist right yes just imagine a light
pulse for a moment and that pulse you
turn the light on you turn it back off
that light energy is going to be
distributed over a sphere right and as
the sphere gets bigger the energy kind
of thins out it gets thinner and thinner
and thinner so as light goes out it gets
dimmer right yes that change can get
real dramatic real fast and so this has
this has its
limits
so you're a biologist I am you know how
we have binocular vision right we have
two eyes which allow us to see you know
some semblance of depth yes human eyes
are anywhere from like 2 to 3 Ines apart
it's like 5 to 8 cm okay this gives us
two different images that our brain kind
of parses out right cuz brains are wild
right there's a discrepancy in where an
object is based on how close it is to
you sure so if you look with one eye
versus is looking with the other eye the
object actually shifts back and forth
and the closer it is to you the more it
shifts sure for human eyes this works
out to say 65 ft or 20 M we we get a
pretty good depth perception out to that
far after that it starts to f through a
little bit things are a little too close
together in the two images for our
brains to parse out how far away they
are sure so we can take advantage of
this binocular vision method
astronomically but we need a much larger
spacing between the images
okay between the eyes sure it's called
stellar parallax mhm this method has
been around for a very long time and so
it's considered sort of the foundation
of the cosmic distance ladder okay we
take a picture of a star and then we
wait 6 months and we take another
picture of a star those eyes are very
far apart I thought they were just going
to be in different spots on the earth no
no the entire diameter of Earth's orbit
okay on average and so essentially what
you get is something like this the earth
goes around the Sun right in its orbit
and so it looks like the star is
wobbling against the background Stars
right it's at one point in the year it's
here against those stars and another
point it's it looks like it's over there
and so what we do is we take those
pictures and then we can measure an
angle between the two images mhm we've
been really good at measuring angles in
the sky for thousands of years sure and
we've been trying to use them to
calculate distances for all of that time
props yes so we essentially figure out
what this angle is and then we just use
trig to figure out the lengths of the
triangles cuz we know how what the
diameter of Earth's orbit is and so then
we should be able to get the other leg
of the triangle yeah that's high school
math right this was the leading way to
measure distances to Stars okay it just
takes a long time it does you kind you
have to you have to do a lot of waiting
right this also has range limits now
these range limits have gotten better
over time as our Technology's gotten
better MH now we have something called
the Gaia space probe I've heard of Gaia
trying to remember what video was I was
I looking up stuff for uh it was the
black hole video oh that was it yeah
you're right Gaia bh1 and Gaia bh2
that's it Gia does a lot of Stellar
observation sure but it's really good at
doing stellar parallax okay it is so
sensitive that it has allowed us to
measure distances out to about 30,000
light years which is a huge portion of
our own Galaxy our galaxy is about
100,000 light years across mhm and so
almost third of the Galaxy just with
Parallax which means those numbers are
solid okay the farther the star gets
from Earth from our sun smaller the Ang
yeah exactly the smaller the angle gets
okay the smaller it gets the harder it
is to measure sure yeah back in like
1920 is the distance we could measure
Parallax out to was only about 300
Lighty years which is still you know
it's still a lot but it's a tiny itty
bitty fraction of her own Galaxy totally
if you talk to some of the roners back
then they might have only trusted the
distances out to like 200 Lighty years
okay 300 was pushing it sure some
scientists said that they could do up to
300 right some very uh The Young Ones
the old ones were like no way get stay
in your lane
kid once you need to step Beyond
Parallax we take advantage of the
problem we ran into with radar ranging
the inverse Square law yes and we can
measure a star as apparent brightness to
us that's easy to do okay this is where
the standard candles come in yes oh no
the trick is we also need to know what
its actual brightness is and how could
you possibly right that's tough right
but we can in some circumstances which
is awesome so here's what it feels like
it feels like you need to know what the
actual brightness is in order to figure
out how far away it is but it also feels
like you would need to know how far away
it is in order to know how bright it
actually is for most stars yes that's
true but not for all of them do tell
about these specialty Stars we had been
looking for standard candles for a long
time I think that first things first you
need to tell us what a standard candle
is well I mean you well we pretty much
yeah okay a standard candle is
essentially a bright object usually a
star that can be used as a standard for
a measuring distances oh okay and so
that's why we call it a standard candle
it's a very descriptive name okay could
be more Des script if you if you called
it a standard Star right the thing is
that back in the day brightness was
measured in terms of
candles okay Stars still existed back in
the day it's not like this is a new
thing just popped up all of a sudden we
actually have this brightness unit which
is based on candles like what the
brightness of a candle would be from one
meter away or something MH candles were
a big deal right candles were kind of
the standard for what brightness was huh
the standard standard candle right and
so when we got to
astronomy it just kind of got used as a
metaphor okay I don't get to name these
things that's on you right so the trick
is to find an object that you can
measure something about to determine its
actual brightness we have actual
brightness and apparent brightness okay
we could take advantage of the inverse
Square law as long as we have both of
these numbers how can you have both of
these numbers without knowing how far
away it is that's a very good
question
there was this type of star that had
been known about for a while they're
called seied variables these Stars
seemed to vary in brightness over time
mhm usually it's anywhere from like 10
to 20 days they can that the Cycles so
like we don't have to wait six months
for this thing we just have to wait like
a couple weeks great and so we can
monitor the brightness of these stars
and the brightness seems to vary it gets
bright and dim and bright and dim mhm
the period of the cycle in brightness is
directly related to their actual
brightness and so if they were a
brighter star then the cycle would be a
particular period And if it was a dimmer
star it would be a different period you
could actually take the period of this
the brightness cycle and calculate a
peak brightness it's not an apparent
brightness an actual brightness we found
a lot of these CIA variables within the
range that Parallax worked mhm
interesting so this is how the rungs are
stacking on top of each other right so
we were able to know how far away those
stars were and use that information to
calibrate the CED variable cycle okay
but seed variables are resolvable out to
about 100 million light years whoa we're
not just talking the distances to stars
or clusters of stars within our own
Galaxy we're talking other galaxies
definitely which we didn't even know
existed at the time yeah far far away
far away from the docks yes ohy Oho and
like I said these things only work out
to about 100 million light years and not
because we have trouble measuring the
brightness but because we have trouble
resolving individual Stars okay and 100
million light years gets us quite away
it it it covers basically our entire
cluster that we're in our entire
Galactic cluster our neighborhood right
not our star neighborhood but our galaxy
neighborhood yes our Galactic
neighborhood
yes
we would like to measure things Beyond
100 million light years never satisfied
right and so we have another really good
standard candle called a type 1A
Supernova those are bright stars tend to
form in binary systems our sun is kind
of an exception to the rule okay we're
kind of a weird star system a lot of the
time one of those stars is a little
bigger and it gets to the end of its
life before the other one does MH and it
will form a white dwarf if the stars are
small enough the stars are like our sun
the thing about white dwarfs is that
they are a stellar Remnant and Stellar
remnants are only stable up to a very
very specific mass value in the case of
white dwarfs that is 1.4 solar masses
that was what your thesis was right yes
let's say a white dwarf formed in a
binary system the other star is still a
star mhm and it starts to siphon Mass
siphon Material off of its companion
which one the white dwarf starts to suck
Mass off of its companion eventually the
mass of the white dwarf is going to grow
to 1.4 solar masses and it's going to
collapse on itself uhoh we're going to
make a black hole if anything survives
it'll make a neutron star but usually
nothing survives ah okay the explosion
is too dramatic okay and so what happens
is it collects enough Mass it hits that
number that 1.4 solar masses and
collapse and explodes okay and because
they always blow up at 1.4 solar masses
we know exactly how bright that
explosion is supposed to be okay how
long are like what kind of time scale
are we talking about here do you know my
guess would be days okay okay when
you're talking about Stellar stuff I
don't know the time scale can be very
long right they are well within you know
a human lifetime okay we began to find
some of these within the 100 million
light years that the seed variables
worked and so we were able to use the
cied variables to calibrate the type 1A
supernovas sure sure and because type 1
a supernovas are so bright we can see
them out much much farther we're looking
at three billion light years wow and so
we have the next wrong on the ladder
sure
sure once we're beyond the range of type
1A supernovas we have to use red shift
it's the I was wondering if that was
going to play a part in this it's the
only thing that we have left mhm
but because some red shift is measurable
within the range of type 1A supernovas
we can use the type 1A supernovas to
calibrate the red shift for distance of
course and so now we have our last rung
on the ladder in fact there are some
distances within the range where red
shift is the only thing that works where
it doesn't even make sense anymore to
mention a distance in parex or Lighty
Years cuz it's just so far right it's so
far away that we end up with significant
ambiguity about what the word distance
even means that's absurd that doesn't
even make sense not only does it become
model dependent but depending on what
kind of distance you want do you want
proper distance the the distance that
they currently are do you want the
distance that they were in the past or
the distance that the light traveled
they're all different so at that point
do you just say that it is far far away
you just say that it's a red shift of
eight you just quote the red shift and
move on and that means something to some
people we have given up because the the
red shift is what matters anyway at that
distance okay so why bother coming up
with a lightyear distance well because
we like to know how far away because we
like to know and so whenever you hear
something oh man this this galaxy that
we just found with jwst is 13 billion
Lighty years away it no it isn't or is
it nobody knows Apparently that is the
distance that the light traveled to get
here okay it traveled 13 billion light
years to get to Earth from where that
Galaxy was when the light left and so
since then it has expanded away from us
for 13 billion years and it is now much
farther it is now much farther away and
we can use models to determine how far
away it currently is but that is model
dependent and so maybe not all that
useful okay and the light is what we're
analyzing anyway sure we might as well
quote the number that the light traveled
that specific Galaxy at that specific
time was that far away no no
no it was a lot closer than that
what because expansion yeah because
remember the light was traveling the
light was traveling for 13 billion years
you're right you're right and so it had
to the light had to travel a lot farther
than that Galaxy was 13 billion years
ago space expanded cuz space expanded
how frustrating for that light that
light is like I'm just trying to get to
the place and then space just keeps
expanding and fighting its travel and so
when we say that this galaxy is 13
billion light years away maybe at some
point but not when that light left and
not when it has arrived uhhuh but you
have to be able to communicate it
somehow right this is information that
has to be able to be communicated if
you're trying to communicate it to a
non-scientist saying well Z equals 6
like that doesn't mean anything to
anybody yeah it's it's far far far away
yeah far far away so far away the
distance doesn't even make sense right
but this is the best we can do for you
and it's going to be farther away than
something that is who's light has been
traveling for less time correct we have
relative yeah distances communication
can occur
yes if we bring this back to the
beginning right when we talk about when
we measure length we want a measuring
device we need access to both ends we
don't really have that with astronomy we
have to be creative we have to use all
these different techniques where we're
measuring something else and then
inferring a distance based on what we
know about physics right and it doesn't
mean that those distances are wrong it
just means that that we're not
technically measuring distance
ultimately we get to really far away
things and it doesn't even make sense to
talk about distance anymore right you
just start talking about something else
instead right that also allows you to
infer how far away something is right in
the end we don't measure distance we
measure something else like time and we
infer distance I mean honestly this is
something that we do in our daily lives
anyway how far is it to thus and such 20
minutes 20 minutes right that we already
do this this is very natural for us
right and so this isn't that much of a
stretch and it isn't any reason to like
question the cosmic distance ladder
we've been developing this thing for a
century MH over a century right and it's
it's really solid okay I'm just going to
sneak in here for a minute to let you
know the next science Asylum video is
already on nebula it's all about the
fact that you can't tell the difference
between being in an accelerating rocket
versus standing on Earth and how that
led to a deeper understanding of gravity
this is going to be hilarious where do
you think you are man well I can't tell
exactly but I feel my weight against the
floor so I'm going to guess this room is
somewhere on Earth nebula is a
creator-owned streaming service with a
mission to empower those creators
everything is completely add and sponsor
free which honestly is how all videos
are meant to be experienced they have a
wide selection of content and it's stuff
I actually watch Joe Scott up and Adam
Uno do of race and more the science
Asylum is there too including our next
video weeks early if you sign up for
nebula using my link below you'll get
access to that video right now you'll
also get a huge discount 40% off that's
only 250 a month for the annual plan 30
bucks gets you everything on nebula for
a year and on that note let's get back
to the cosmic distance
ladder we climbed the ladders got all
the way up all the way up and it's quite
a way yeah well on that note until next
time remember it's okay to be a little
crazy many of you pointed out on the
last video that it's odd for NASA to
name a telescope after an administrator
and you know what that's that's fair
it's an unusual choice if it were me I
probably would have chosen a scientist
but the point I was trying to make in
that video is that the name wasn't
offensive anyway thanks for
watching